it is my honor to present the Oscar for
achievement in directing every one of
them did an extraordinary job of
bringing their vision to the screen the
nominees are
for The Aviator Martin Scorsese Million
Dollar Baby Clint Eastwood for a Taylor
Hackford for sideways Alexander Payne
Revere Drake might lead
and the Oscar goes to Clint Eastwood
this is the third Academy Award
nomination for Clint Eastwood in this
category he was previously nominated for
Mystic River and Unforgiven for which he
wanted directing Oscar in 1992
thank you I'd like to thank my wife was
my best pal down here and my mother who
was here with me in 1993 she was only 84
then but she's here with me again
tonight and she just
so at 96 I'm thanking her for her jeans
as it's was a wonderful adventure it
takes a to make a picture in 37 days
takes a well-oiled machine and that
well-oiled machine is the crew of the
cast of course you've met a lot of them
but but there's still there's still
Margo and Anthony and and and Michael
and Mike and and and Jay and and and
everybody else who was so fabulous in
this cast and and the the crew
Campanelli and and Billy Coe and of
course Tom Stern it was fantastic and
and Henry Bumstead the great Henry bump
said who is the head of our crack
geriatrics team and and Henry and Jack
Taylor and Dick Goddard all those guys
and Walt and everybody I can't think of
everybody now I'm going to get at blank
but Warren you were right and and thank
you for your confidence early in the
evening and I'm just lucky to be here
lucky to be still working and I watched
Sidney lameta out there who's 80 and and
I figure hey I'm just a kid I'll just I
just I've got a lot of stuff to do yet
so thank you all very much
appreciate it